du cinéma avec la sortie du poids lourd
de la semaine astérix aux jeux
olympiques le film de tous les records
budget de près de 80 millions d'euros
gérard depardieu alain delon benoît
poelvoorde mais aussi amélie mauresmo ou
zinedine zidane au générique est
également clovis cornillac dans le rôle
d'astérix
il sera avec nous dans un instant
d'abord les impressions à la sortie de
la première séance cet après-midi
françois jullien pieds-noirs guillaume
michel
10h15 première séance de la journée à
cette heure ci dans la queue forcément
que des connaisseurs
j'ai toutes les bd chez moi j'ai vu tous
les films les eschois donc voilà je vais
voir les derniers déjà cas là que
l'armée à mon avis ce soir ça va être la
folie
1h53 de projection et un budget
olympique 78 millions d'euros le plus
gros film de l'histoire du cinéma
français autour des milliers de
figurants de chevaux être costumes un
casting impérial
la présentation du film semblait très
rigolote et c'est moyennement rigolo
j'adorais ça m'a fait rigoler qu'est ce
qui t'as plus de plus dans le film bat
ou en fonds publics à ma hauteur il
était un petit peu déçue de ne pas avoir
beaucoup astérix obélix dire que la star
s'est passé et qui s'est passé à 80 star
d'un film et javascript et pourtant
clovis cornillac en moustachu dopés à la
potion magique a séduit les plus jeunes
est vraiment pas mal parce que il fait
beaucoup de grimaces par rapport à
l'ancien qui faisait pas beaucoup de
grimaces là il s'exprime vraiment le
film sort sur 6000 écran en europe un
tour de force pour dépasser le précédent
film et ses 15 millions d'entrées voilà
bon